très longtemps que le québec rêvait de
pouvoir servir la ville de new york en
électricité une grande entente une belle
affaire et pour l'été les époux
d'honneur et pour mieux
hydro québec a obtenu quand même non dit
le plus important contrat d'exportation
de son histoire charline hatsune power
express c'est 1250 mégawatts sur 25 ans
dès 2025 pour alimenter new york en
électricité propre est ce une bonne
affaire sur toute la ligne pour les
québécois notre ca du vendredi avec jean
thomas bernard professeur invité au
département de sciences économiques de
l'université d'ottawa et normand
mousseau au directeur scientifique de
l'institut d'énergie trottier professeur
associé à polytechnique montréal bon
soir
enfin pouvoir normand mousseau d'abord
est ce que est ce un bon d'accord
qu'hydro pourrait finalement parce qu'il
reste la signature la conque